[Music]
hello and welcome to Week in Review with
meet Jillian Joseph Kevin McGuire and
Andrew Pierce are here to look back at
the biggest stories of the past seven
days so what were your top stories
gentlemen o mine was the unfairness of
Boris Johnson been hammered by downing
street for telling the truth on Saudi
Arabia and Iran unfairness mm-hmm the MP
is finally doing the right thing or
breaks it that therefore making the
entire supreme court hearing utterly
pointless well brexit took center stage
in both the Supreme Court and the House
of Commons there was furious debate and
legal argument over when the government
should start the process of leaving the
EU and whether it even had the right to
without the consent of MPs skies senior
news correspondent Michelle Clifford
reports on the conclusion of the
four-day hearing the government's top
law officer was back in court the
morning after MPs voted to back the
Prime Minister's timing on brexit but
the Attorney General will still have to
wait to hear whether Theresa May will be
able to start the process at all
presenting their submissions lawyers for
concerned citizens some Britons living
abroad others EU citizens living in
Britain Helen montfield QC representing
expats was to the point exiting the EU
she said would lead to a lot of rights
and only Parliament can sanction that
and what of responsibility to protect
the children of Europeans living in
Britain asked Manjit Gill QC his legal
presentation was infused with a motive
language as he warned of what could
happen to EU citizens here post breaks
it be ready to pack your bags and go on
that day it's that stock because we're
not going to give you any guarantees in
fact we're going to get you use you as a
bargaining chip it's reading there was
mentioning closing by the government of
that vote in parliament James ed QC
saying it may not be legally binding but
it is legally relevant the justices must
now go away and decide what if any
bearing it has on the case we are not
being asked to overturn the result of
the EU referendum the ultimate question
in this case concerns the process by
which that result could lawfully be
brought into effect we appreciate that
this case should be resolved as quickly
as possible and we will do our best to
it achieve that thank you again
everybody the court is now adjourned so
what did you make of the four-day
hearing it's quite quite interesting
isn't it really I mean who are the
enemies of the people now is that the
judges upholding the law as the MPs who
holding the law to they speak for
Britain the MPS but the judges are
supposed to be the enemies of people
look Parliament sovereign Parliament
should decide to trigger article 50
we're going to leave Europe because
people vote to do that but the terms and
the time should be decided by MPs rather
than the Prime Minister behaving like a
medieval monarch the whole point of the
court case now it's it isn't it's
nothing void it's redundant because
parlor is now voted for the time today
where the judges cannot now say you
can't trigger article 50 because it's
going to be as as agreed in march
towards the end of march she showed a
little bit of ankle the Prime Minister
she wants a red line and immigration we
knew that before that probably means
we're leaving the single market we knew
that before she didn't really tell part
at Parliament anything we didn't know
already but she called she called labor
was bluff and she's got a massive
mandate now to trigger article 15
suppose the positive is she's made
labour really show their hand on that
commons vote absolutely quite a number
of Labour MPs abstained and there are
one or two I think there was 71 voted
against and they will now be heavily
targeted by you Kip I think they could
be in big trouble look later some time
ago had made quite clear that it
accepted the result of the referendum
and brexit lib dems are still
challenging it the S&P are still
challenging it for their own reasons
valek Mears made a real mess of this she
should have from the very beginning
champion the sovereignty of Parliament
which actually a lot of people said they
were voting for on the brexit on the
brexit referendum and just made a great
thing of it instead of appealing going
all this trouble or it's fascinating to
watch but all the abuse that people have
had for st. Parliament should stand that
was being another disgrace so that's our
top story in a busy newsweek so here are
five things you might have missed out
the head of mi6 has warned Russian
actions in Syria could put Britain
security at risk speaking for the first
time inside the group's headquarters
Alex younger said the war-torn country
faces a tragic outcome in defining as a
terrorist anyone who opposes a brutal
regime they alienate precisely that
group that has to be on side if the
extremists are to be defeated meanwhile
in Aleppo Russian and the Syrian Russia
and the Syrian regime seek to make a
desert and call it first the human
tragedy is heartbreaking Labour MP
Luciana Berger called for more victims
of online abuse to come forward she was
speaking after a 24 year old man was
jailed for tears not being convicted of
racially aggravated harassment for
posting anti-semitic blogs about the
politician Italy's Prime Minister stood
down Matteo Renzi staked his job on
winning a referendum which would have
changed the country's lawmaking process
however mr. Renzi suffered a heavy
defeat in the boat leaving Italy looking
for a new government John Glenn the
first American astronaut to orbit the
Earth has died at the age of 95 he was
the only the fifth person to ever enter
space and later represented Ohio as a
Democratic senator President Obama was
among those to pay tribute to mr. Glenn
and now for the gaff of the week it goes
to Boris Johnson never shy of an opinion
but this time his views on Saudi Arabia
landed him in hot water with the Prime
Minister there are politicians who are
twisting and abusing religion and and
and different strains of the same
religion in order to further their their
own political objectives and that's one
of the biggest problems in though
political problems in the whole region
that's why you've got international you
got the societies the Iran everybody
moving in and and puppeteering and
playing proxy wars did he say what many
are thinking
to fear to speak out on well I think you
did I told the truth he tells the truth
in private often not in in public Teresa
made the promise has just been in the in
the region and she kowtow to the Saudis
are hand chopping women veiling allies
because they celoso island by are on so
she has to be nicer but she she's right
Iran and Saudi Arabia export a very
violent form of Islam that is disrupting
and destroy in that region but you see
it's very easy for people like McGuire
to condemn our relationship with Saudi
Arabian of course it is an appalling
regime and it's very anti women but
billions of pounds worth of business is
done between Britain and Saudi Arabia
tens of thousands of jobs in this
country depend on our trade with Saudi
Arabia and what are we going to just
give them away put these people on the
dole destroy communities let the French
take the job because they don't go it's
launched on trial ethical foreign policy
remember Robin Cook had an ethical
foreign policy it lasted about three
months when you knew what you wanted to
sell some planes to East Timor which is
involved in a civil war it was abandoned
by come on human rights are universal
you should not shut your eyes to what is
going out or job Syd you do not want
your eyes and it is ridiculous that
foreign secretary and as you know I'm
not his biggest fan but he's cut down
for telling the truth you didn't know it
is we do you know art about what happens
to those a contest though between the
jobs and yes ignoring he device called
the real world it's called we do
business with all sorts of countries
that have terrible ratings what about
China not great or you might what about
Russia we do business with countries all
around but why do we always sing about
Saudi Arabia which is one of our most
important trading part I hold on sales
now to Saudi Arabia when they're using
them against civilians in the Yemen and
slaughtering people don't forget send us
your nominations using the hashtag W in
our Week in Review now this week months
of uncertainty for thousands of British
steel workers came to an end they
received a five-year commitment from
Tata to guarantee jobs at its port
tolbert site and other still works
across the country skies Rebecca
Williams reports now from the plant in
South Wales
with Christmas on the way there's
finally something to celebrate in Port
Talbot as a deal in principles finally
been reached to secure jobs and
investment in the plant this deal in
principle won't just protect jobs it
will also secure both blast furnaces and
there will be 1 billion pounds worth of
investment in Port Talbot over the next
10 years but there will be a compromise
and that's likely to be over the pension
scheme the plant here invests in every
aspect of the community and for people
like Gary Keogh who's worked at the
plant for three decades today's news is
a relief we haven't slept a great deal a
lot of us to you officials are younger
Norma great Pele be perfectly honest it
is a relief but there is always a caveat
on the british teen tension there is a
transformation plan working towards all
whether a bitter of 200 million pounds
that ensures that we are able to invest
into the future of the plant that also
invests that there is nobody gives
better guarantee than financial
performance and that's the best job
guarantee you can give this is an
agreement in principle but the final
decision will be put to a ballot in the
new year do we think this seemingly good
news is all it appears to be well it
stated will the end of the final salary
pension scheme Wichita have been after
for some time but it's a great victory
for the workers and the trade unions
down there the the Welsh Government
Labour government Carwyn Jones the First
Minister because Todd we're going to
show that and the government your
government your Tory government i first
was just standing so far back it was
going to do nothing was going to let it
go up the wall well it didn't go to I
think it's fantastic news the pension is
it an unfortunate compromise but it's
not just that the jobs are protected
it's the billion pounds of investment
which is quite an important vote of
confidence and I know we'll be back in
five years performance-based their coops
and in five years time we'll be back
with another review but just imagine
this news coming just before Christmas
to that town would die without the
steelworks the Tata to it there's no
doubt about it it is portal but which is
why it's so important it survives we've
still got an address the issue of cheap
Chinese
imports hear them exporting cheap steel
here because the European Union's being
better at fighting that than your gum
told and I think the government has to
say if we do go ahead with that you too
Chris high-speed rail link let's make
sure we're using British steel in fact
why not some steel from Port Talbot okay
thank you time now for quiz of the week
quick quiz for you why was there hope
for people who think that there aren't
enough hours in the day they don't know
her do you we'll find out after the
break welcome back to week in review
with me Gillian Joseph i'm joined by
kevin maguire associate editor of The
Daily Mirror and Andrew Pierce
consultant editor of The Daily Mail well
before the break we asked why was they
good news for people who think that
there aren't enough hours in the day any
ideas Lewis not luckily completely
clueless yes well good basic but on this
subject well it's because scientists are
predicting that in the future there will
be 25 hours in the day you know why no
because the speed of the Earth's orbit
is slowing wrote sober well the negative
side is that for people who think
they'll soon have extra time to do
everything it's not quite that simple
darm universities experts say we're only
gaining two milliseconds per century
will be meaning though let's if you can
do the math meaning we'll take how long
for us to gain in a long time 200
million years right what if there's
reincarnation yes L will be long gone
like I could always do with an extra 12
hours in the day it's never ever imagine
having 25 hours of Kevin McGuire that's
enough people would like like two
minutes more that's 60 minutes to like
you of people that might like exactly so
every will have to look for the he's so
rude now we heard this week that areas
of Britain are struggling to cope with
integration of diverse communities and
the pace and scale of change caused by
immigration skies Lisa Holland visited
Oldham to speak to people there the
former mill town of Oldham attracted
mass migration from South Asia
in the 50s and 60s but a generation on
barriers are still to be broken down
which even residents admit means parts
of the town of virtually segregated why
people like live in the wrong way and
then obviously asian people got on
religions on we're looking things and
that's choice us in the day though
British as I am as well but you quite
like this to stay as a mostly white area
I'll just sell out what's on in versus
yeah the assistant marries an area where
black and white residents appear to live
happily side by side if a lot of Asian
people moved into this street how would
you feel about that want to move oh why
would that upset you to live next door
to an Asian person could smell it you're
so not dear some food and things they're
not the smell of the Asian field
validation food dingler glottic is a
predominantly asian area of Oldham I
believe personally it's one of the most
segregated Tom's in the country
shopkeeper retief Hussein and travel
agent parvez Nazir on neighbors they say
some residents rarely leave the
community people are segregated aren't
they by choice you know they've got
they've got a choice of where they want
to live and they want to live in a
segregated community yeah they wanna
live in Sicarii sorry why is notice to
be honest it's a lot of people around
here feel safer together residents say
segregation doesn't make where they live
no-go areas though many are in a comfort
zone they will never leave hmm does that
report surprise you I reported no I
think I think it was a good report
actually and she didn't put a punji to
Louise Casey I think is called the
cohesion czar or some such thing and she
was making the point to that some of the
problems of the multiculturalism
segregations that it reinforces some
pretty bad habits in some of these
communities for women in particular so
some women she said she met weren't
allowed out the house because the
husbands don't let them they're not
allowed to get jobs they're not allowed
to go and learn English and she was
saying as a prerequisite now immigrants
should be encouraged made to learn
English because that will help well
help them because a lot of those people
living in poverty they can't get jobs
and part the problem is they don't speak
English yeah and it's a shame the
government cut English classes but I
want a fully multicultural society so
you want everybody to be involved and
there is segregation you get it in
working-class white communities wherever
there's poverty little educational
opportunities and you can get it with
some groups who arrived and this has
happened all through our history with
the Hyuga NORs the Irish Jewish people
coming from Easton Eastern Europe people
come from the West Indies and they they
will integrate down the line but you
gotta you gotta push it you gotta push
for it and you've got to entice them out
as well and not just condemn them and
you know we need people to mix we're
much better when everybody mixes okay
let's take a look at the newspapers now
and your choices of the top stories
Andrew another week for Donald Trump it
gently him who else could it be really
personally he won that election against
all the odds he upset the applecart
upset the Republican Party he wasn't
supposed to win I think he's been quite
measured by comparison since he's become
president elect with some of his
outrageous utterances during the
election campaign but he's the
president-elect of the United States in
a few weeks time he's going to be the
most powerful man on the planet of
course he had to win it Nigel Farage was
apparently a strong contender no legal
way buddy visit important person here
look love on my loathe him you gotta
admit these mirrielees mark and i'm
still a setter a line race a sexual
predator will be in the White House and
the set of draining the swamp he's
filling the Washington swamped with all
he's a loony right-wing MIT but just a
word of warning he's Man of the Year
this yeah Hitler was in nineteen thirty
yeah they went a bit wrong didn't it
Person of the Year Moscow person you're
quite longer manager yeah but I mean
it's not about a popularity contest it's
who's had the most influential better
asian wife and I wasn't got it and I
side I suspect if we had that had it in
this country time's person of the year
in Britain would probably be Nigel for
us because he is the reason we've got
Briggs it yeah I vote for Kevin at the
end of network rail is it yeah Transport
Secretary Chris Grayling no I things in
the finger tip club
tries to hang on his job in the cabinet
has decided that a new line between
oxford and cambridge will be completely
privatized and network rail which is
publicly owned won't be doing the track
i think it's a mistake he wants to
cherry-pick bits of Network Rail I'm
sure to privatize the maintenance had to
be brought back in-house to be done
publicly because it was such a disaster
in the private sector and I fear is I
going to get out the same route and make
the same mistake this reminds me of Nero
fiddling while Rome is burning because
while he's making this speech about a
few about one small railway line we've
got the worst industrial unrest on
Southern Railway we've ever had so both
as left and and the RMT are on strike
for days there's going to be strikes all
the way up to Christmas and the
government are washing their hands that
they're doing nothing about it commuters
are in utter despair and you've seen a
Tory MP a loyalist Bob Neill calling for
Chris grading the sector state to be
sacked because it is such a shambles
drilling could hold on industrial action
but click avisa fingers by by going the
teens reason cantilever taking in
destination because that's a franchise
they've given her it's directly managed
they're using a private company and
they've deliberately picked a fight with
the workers they deliberately picked it
and the commuters are suffering as a
result it appalling let's move on to
junk food advertising but online yeah
well social media is now at last being
bought into line with the rest of the
media so junk food for targeted at
children under the age of 16 it's long
been banned on television it's going to
be banned now in newspapers but on
social media too and its food that's
high in fat sugar salt and I think it's
a pretty good idea because it's aimed at
trying to tackle the growing obesity
crisis amongst our children there are so
many fat fat kids at school because
they're eating the wrong food and the
appetizers of shamelessly targeted them
on social media and they spend more time
on social media my team lunch meeting
facebook has two fagan the others have
to face up with their social
responsibilities because now kids are
more likely to grow up Abby's than they
are to get a decent job own their own
home or get a good pension finally have
you got one of these a five-pound note
with a little etching and ingredients
20,000 these wall
I've seen it before there it's a
fantastic four of the new five-pound
notes have a little etching of Jane
Austen on them it could be worth 50
grand if you have one too Jane Austen if
you have Steve Austin have six million
dollars you'll get for it cool but
nevertheless you could just pick it up
just see it you can just see it the
engravings but it's fantastic looking
what were those ludacris vegans do if
they get that fiber will they cash in
the 50,000 pounds yeah oh oh well the
show I can't touch it because it's got
animal fat in it gently forget that I
needs Al's 50,000 my vegans are upset
about this as they're not meant to be
eaten maybe I don't think we should have
animal products in products it got jet
exam with the Hindus object to get over
it well thanks for taking us through the
newspapers what about your ups and downs
let's start with you Andrew it's gotta
be giraffes because there's been this
astonishing report saying that they are
facing extinction because of poaching
and loss of wildlife habitat but because
of this report now it actually means
there's going to be huge efforts and
conservation to save them because their
numbers have gone down dramatically I've
even seen a drop they are adorable
creatures they really are wonderful i
had the mime animals lying all along
gain lien is so lovely so it's good good
at this for reports come out so we're
sending at giraffes up this is annex to
stop itching story this student could
fire siddiqui 38 he's suing oxford
university for a million pounds because
he said his failure to get a first-class
degree as customer million pounds in
lost earnings he's suffering from
insomnia and depression I feel sorry if
he's on if he's on well but what's
happened now the charging of phases
people believe that buying degrees and
you pay your money is almost expectation
you're going to get Warbeck genet when
he took his degree in two thousand white
in 16 years to realize it's the
university to blow anything say the
teaching was bad he also said the
teaching was boring i don't know you can
get a refund for that well I don't we've
all blame boring teachers have a well
you haven't done so well they didn't
hear you got a 2-1 yeah yeah it's all
right more that got that's where I got
anything Kevin right let's move on we
didn't go you got to go to university
together to agree to this is Lady new g
Emily I she's named by her husband who
was fantastic at Prime Minister's
Questions & will now challenge those who
always run her down like him no she's a
barrel well not a single question on the
list with a Labour MP 50 you just can't
stand council house people who do well
did you not think her performance for
skip day it was better nicer than I
expected and frankly anything is better
than comedy Corbin values useless better
i disgusted from Andrew Pierce means
five stars oscar-winning get your gold
she better than corpn he's actually not
being bad in recent weeks but he's very
hit and miss she was a big hit she did
that's the same question several times
but that was it perseverance because he
couldn't have the government couldn't
answer whether or not we're going to
stay in the customs union in Europe
Kevin what else Oh going down is cricket
always considered itself a gentleman's
game they're going to introduce red
cards because there's so much bad
language people threatening they hit
each other with bats it's just got like
football do you notice that if of sexism
thing gentleman's game women play
cricket to you can do but i think you
will look at this picture and you will
see there are two men yeah including
that's that from a hundred years ago is
that covered okay there's a very very
good okay okay step Rachel hey hopefully
right very important it's in the house a
long time in the show Maris women's
unintentional sex is like yeah I'm
guilty no I'm never get any tension it
steady next to him I've caught his bad
where's so we are sending this down yup
cricket there it goes there it goes now
don't forget to you can send us your
nominations using the hashtag week in
review w in our thanks for joining us in
our review of the week we'll be back for
more next week but
now it's goodbye from that goodbye and
it's goodbye from me
[Music]